Hello world, it's Saroj and
let's talk about optimization.
There are thousands of languages
spoken across the world,
each one unique in its ability to
represent concepts and convey ideas,
but there is one language
that is shared by all humans.
Regardless of where you come from.
Mathematics,
no matter your culture or your age,
you possess the ability to understand
this language of numbers that connects us
all across continents and time.
Like all languages.
Fluency requires practice,
but unlike any other language,
the more fluent you become in math,
the more unstoppable you'll be in
anything you want to do in life.
Math is happening all around us to a
degree that most people don't realize.
We can think of everything
as a set of variables,
as metrics and there exists relations
between all of these variables.
In math we call these relations functions.
It's our way of representing
a set of patterns, a mapping,
a relationship between at many variables,
no matter what machine
learning model we use,
no matter what Ada sent we use.
The goal of machine learning is to
optimize or unobjective and by doing so we
are approximating a function.
The process of optimization helps us
iteratively discover a functions hidden in
the depths of data.
Last week we talked about a popular
optimization technique called gradient
descent. This can be broken
down into a five step process.
First,
we define some machine learning model
with a set of initial weight values.
These act as the coefficients of the
function at the model represents the
mapping between input data
and output predictions.
These values aren't naive.
We have no idea what
they should actually be,
but we're trying to
discover the optimal ones.
We'll define an error function
and when we plot the graph up,
the relationship between all the possible
error values and all of the possible
weight values for our function will
see that there exists a valley,
a minimum.
We'll use our error to help us compute
the partial derivative with respect to
each weight value we have and
this gives us our gradient.
The gradient represents the change in
the air when the weights are changed by a
very value from their original value.
We use the gradient to update the values
of our weights in a direction such that
the error is minimized iteratively coming
closer and closer to the Minima of the
function.
We step our solution in the negative
direction of the gradient repeatedly when
we reach it.
We have learned the optimal weight values
for our model where our gradient is
equal to zero.
Our model,
we'll then be able to make predictions
for input data it's never seen before.
Most optimization problems can be
solved using gradient descent and its
variance.
They all fall into a category called
first order optimization methods.
We call them first order because they
only require us to compute the first
derivative,
but there's another class of techniques
that aren't as widely used called second
order optimization methods that require
us to compute the second derivative.
The first derivative tells us if the
function is increasing or decreasing at a
certain point and the second derivative
tells us if the first derivative is
increasing or decreasing,
which hints at its curvature.
First order methods provide us with a
line that is tangential to a point on an
air surface and second order methods
provide us with a quadratic surface that
kisses the curvature of the error
surface. Ah, get a room you youtube.
The advantage then of second order
methods is that they don't ignore the
curvature of the error surface and
in terms of stepwise performance,
they are better.
Let's look at a popular second order
optimization technique called Newton's
method named after the dude who
invented calculus, whose name was
there are actually two
versions of Newton's method.
The first version is for finding
the roots of a polynomial,
all those points where it
intersects with the x axis.
So if you throw a ball and
recorded his trajectory,
finding the roots of the equation,
we'll tell you exactly what
time it hits the ground.
The second version is for optimization
and it's what we use in machine learning,
but let's code the route finding virgin
first to develop some basic intuition.
Okay.
Elouise of ICML Bay and you're welcome.
Hi,
good to meet you and your to the
how to coordinate on that part.
Not yet.
It's going to be quite a challenge.
We've got to perform anomaly
detection on a 500 terabyte data sets.
I was thinking just do Snoopy's method,
just the progression first to see if we
can predict particles. Newton's method.
Yeah,
it's a form like in the arm optimization,
I already build props was training
for the past few hours. I'm impressed.
Machine Learner, we shoot, let's
say we have a function f of x
and some initial guests solution.
Newton's method says that we first find
the slope of the tangent line at our
guest's point.
Then find the point at which the
tangent line intersects the x axis.
We'll use that point to find its
projection in the original function.
Then we iterate again from our first
step this time replacing our first point.
With this one we keep
iterating and eventually we'll
stop when our current value
of x is less than or equal to a threshold,
so that's the route finding version of
Newton's method where we're trying to
find where the function equal zero,
but in the optimization version we're
trying to find where the derivative of the
function equal zero. It's
minimum. At a high level,
given a random starting location,
we construct a quadratic approximation
to the objective function that matches
the first and second derivative
values at that point,
and then we minimize that quadratic
function instead of the original function.
The minimizer of the quadratic function
is used as a starting point in the next
step and we repeat this
process iteratively. Okay,
so let's go over to cases of Newton's
method for optimization to learn more.
A One d case and a two d case.
In the first case,
we've got a one dimensional function.
We can obtain a quadratic approximation
at a given point of the function using
what's called a Taylor series expansion.
Neglecting terms of order three or higher.
A Taylor series is a representation of
a function as an infinite sum of terms
that are calculated from the values of
the functions derivatives at a single
point.
It was invented by an English
mathematician named Brooke Taylor Swift.
Just kidding.
So we take the second order
tailored series for our
initial point x and minimize
it by finding the first derivative and
second derivative and equating them to
zero in order to find the minimum x value.
We iterate this process.
In the second case,
let's say we've got a function
of multiple dimensions,
we can find the minimum of it using the
same approach except for two changes.
We replaced the first derivatives with
a gradient and the second derivatives
with a Hessian Hessian is a matrix of
the second order partial derivatives of a
scaler and it describes the local
curvature of a multivariable function.
Check this out.
Derivatives help us compute gradients
which we can represent using aged Cobian
matrix for first order optimization and
we can use the Hessian for second order
optimization.
These are four of the five
derivative operators using all of,
they're the ways that we organize
and represent change numerically.
So when should you use
a second order method?
First order methods are usually less
computationally expensive to compute and
less time expensive,
converging pretty fast on large datasets.
Second order methods are faster when the
second derivative is known and easy to
compute,
but the second derivative is often in
tractable to compute requiring lots of
computation for certain problems.
Gradient descent can get stuck along
paths of slow convergence around saddle
points,
whereas second order methods won't.
Trying out different
optimization techniques for
your specific problem is the
best way to see what works best.
Here are the key points to
remember from this video.
First order optimization techniques use
the first derivative of the function to
minimize it. Second order optimization
techniques use a second derivative.
The Jacoby Ian is a matrix of first
partial derivatives and the Hessian is a
matrix of second partial derivatives
and Newton's method is a popular second
order optimization technique that can
sometimes outperform gradient descent.
Last week's coding challenge winner is
Alberto Garcia sets Alberto used gradient
descent to find the line of best fit
is Jupiter notebook is insanely detail.
You could learn gradient descent
just from reading it alone.
Very well thought out. That was
dope. Alberto wizard of the week,
and the runner up is Ivan Gustaf who
implemented gradient descent from scratch
for polynomials of any order.
This week's challenge is to implement
Newton's method for optimizations from
scratch.
Details are in the read me poster,
get hub link in the comments and
winners will be announced next week.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos,
and for now I've got to invent the sixth
derivative, so thanks for watching.